It's an incredible story of survival.
Nearly three weeks ago, this dog Mason was picked up by a tornado that ravaged Alabama.
His owners frantically searched for their beloved dog,...
...but began to give up hope.
Then on Monday, they returned to what was left of their home...
...and found their terrier mix waiting on the porch.
He's got two broken legs and they're distal radioulnar fractures.
They've not been able to be in alignment so neither one of them have healed,...
...so he had to crawl on two broken legs to get home.
Mason's owners have asked a local animal shelter to take care of him...
...while they try to put their own lives back together.
This is probably the most dramatic that we've seen...
...as far as an injury in an animal that's survived this long.
And an animal clinic has volunteered to help nurse him back to health.
He called and asked if there was anything he could do last week...
...and this dog appeared today and so I called him and never a hesitation,...
...he offered, "Bring it on over." and he'd do what he could do.
Mason will have surgery on his broken legs, Friday.
Doctors say while his recovery will be long,...
...ultimately they believe that will be successful.
For an animal to go what he's gone through and not to be ugly,...
...to be, you know, happy for human companionship is remarkable...
...and we're honored to be a part of his recovery.
A true survivor indeed.